hi my name is Christopher ger Tony I'm a
high school mathematics teacher at
William from high school in palatine
illinois and my talk today will be co
presented with some of my former
students and we'll be talking about
using wolfram demonstrations in a high
school classroom as a capstone project
for seniors
I thanks everybody for being here today
my name is Chris were Tony I'm a high
school teacher at William from high
school in palatine illinois and we're
going to be talking about wolfram
demonstrations and this is a capstone
project that we do at fremd high school
with our multivariable calculus students
and i have some special guests with me
today i have some former fremd graduates
who have gone created this project in
the past so we have robert andrews we
have Danny Johnson I want to block you
Kevin we have Kevin kraut and then we
have Matt Nicholson Roshan Rajan and
berwyn she and so they're going to talk
a little bit about the projects they
created what they're up to now in their
educational life and what sort of impact
the project had for them but first I
thought I'd give you guys a little bit
of background about the project itself
so this is the an excerpt from the
project description that that I hand out
to all of the students it's at the end
of the year after AP testing so the
students will finish their final exam
for the calc three course that they're
taking and then we have usually have
about three to four weeks at the end of
the school year after that final exam
has taken place there's AP testing and
then there's a couple weeks at the end
of the school year after that and so
their task is to create a Wolfram demo
that basically highlights an interesting
mathematical or scientific or just
otherwise interesting idea that they're
passionate about or interested in and
I'm guessing that most of you have seen
the wolfram demonstrations project
before but if not Berman do you want to
just show really quickly it would be
just in the web browser I had pulled it
up I didn't know if we were gonna have
internet or not so I have had it ready
but I wasn't planning on necessarily
using it so of those ten thousand nine
hundred and twenty-two published
projects about 30 of them have been
published by from Thai school students
and there's all sorts of different
topics that they that they have created
for those yeah you can that's great
berwyn yeah
that's right let's go back to the slide
show then wait we don't want to wait for
it oh okay came up um so that's uh
there's 27 of them listed there and then
some students forget to put from high
school in their description so they
don't come up when they when you search
homes there's a few more than those 27
and you can see all sorts of different
different subjects so now I kind of
classified later on in the presentation
what what subjects they picked but so
the main thing that I try to communicate
to the students if you do try a project
like this in your own classroom is I
tell them to try not to be overly
ambitious with the scope of their
project because some students try to
take on the world and make this huge
project this really complicated demo
that they're not going to finish in
three weeks and so we try to try to keep
them small and interesting and into the
point and the main thing is that the
demonstration should help the user learn
more about the subject that they're
interested in through interactivity so
that's the that's the main goal of it
and it doesn't have to be calc three
some students will make a calc three
project most students pick something
else they're just passionate about
berwyn we can keep moving a little bit
about from to high school and some
contextual information about our
students so like I said it's a capstone
project for calc three students at this
point they have just finished a
multivariable calculus a calc three
course through the University of
Illinois their net math program the
we're part of the partner high school
program with the University of Illinois
and so they once they have finished that
that full curriculum they're kind of
ready to take on a project like this at
this point in the year the students are
comfortable with plotting things in
Mathematica they're comfortable with
solving interesting problems in
Mathematica they're they're comfortable
with spherical and cylindrical
coordinate systems they know how to show
multiple graphics objects in one plot
and they do know how to make simple
manipulates they do know how to make a
make a graph and drag a slider and
somehow change that graph in some
interesting ways so they they do have a
background that that has them prepared
for a project like this burrow and I
think we can keep going and one thing
that I've learned from numerous years of
doing a project like this is that you
need to lay
ground work early the first year that I
that I did this project I just threw it
at the students at the end of the year
and it was it was still fun and they had
a good time with it but only one project
got published and it was because all at
once i was asking a lot of those
students and so what we started to do
over the years is build up to what this
is I'm so berwyn if you want to expand
tip number one I try to assign projects
throughout the year that encourage
creativity throughout throughout the
entire school year I mean it could be as
small as an art project this is actually
built into the University of Illinois
net math curriculum so this isn't
something that I invented myself but
it's something that I make a big deal
out of in class and the students really
get into we do a spherical and
cylindrical coordinate art contest so
burn if you want to expand that so this
happens about halfway through the school
year those that picture right there are
those are all images that students have
made themselves completely in
Mathematica those are all so it's not
like they were dragging and dropping
anything and it's not like those are
graphics primitives even those are all
cylindrical and spherical coordinates
and it's kind of hard to see but even
that bb-8 and I wouldn't want to expand
the code for the bb-8 because it might
crash the project is a ton of it but
every little detail on that droid is is
actually a spherical coordinate plot and
if you scroll down we can see a couple
of those a little bit closer so there's
a Mickey Mouse that a student made last
year that was one of our big winners
there's Cloud City and then there's bb-8
but when i'm curious can we rotate bb-8
at all because i think from all angles
he's pretty cool or is that it isn't an
image darn ok and if you are curious if
you download this presentation all of
the code is there in a hidden cell so
you can't expand it and see for yourself
but and I do have some other fun little
things that have happened in class over
the years and two of the students
involved are here today so Kevin you can
go first yeah um so
I had to think of an idea in order to
ask a girl to prom and I thought what
nerdier and more fun way than to use
mathematica to ask girl to prom so I got
mr. guru Tony's help to set up under the
guise of helping everyone with their
end-of-the-year project and just made a
brief slider that drew some cylinders
asking a girl to prom with me so it was
really fun and she did say yes she did
yeah I also a greater one it's a couple
years later yes and independence of
Kevin you didn't even know that Kevin
had done that if I recall but yeah I was
also asking someone to prom and I
thought it would be a fun little thing
because they were also taking the same
class with me through the net math
program so that semester i was taking
that euros taking differential equations
so i wanted to do something a little bit
more focused around that so i used one
of the topics which was fourier
transforms so i had a bunch of these
images which i did an edge translate
based on Michael trots code he has a
parametric of certain images so I kind
of extracted kind of the creative parts
that I wanted to use and then added my
own version to kind of come up with this
giant grid of different images that I
got call us to the proposal um and for
me particularly that was in the work
that you did Roshan I thought I was
really excited about that because he
took a blog post that someone at Wolfram
had had written had written you read it
you understood it and then you
incorporated it and learned what was in
there so that was as a teacher that was
a very you know awesome moment for me so
and then the other tip that I have is if
you do try a project like this in your
own classroom is to mention the project
early and often the sooner that the
students know that they're going to make
something like that the sooner the the
gears are turning and that they're
thinking about what they could create
and honestly at this point after doing
the project for since 2012 at this point
usually when we get to the project stage
of things the students already pretty
much know what they want to want to make
I'm though I've seen
in physics they're like oh I can make a
demo of that or those they'll see
something in a Wolfram blog post and say
oh I could I could take that idea and go
in this direction with it which which
helps a lot because then they're not
spinning their wheels for the first week
of the project just trying to think of
what they're going to create it also
sets the expectations high because early
in the year I will show them what
previous students have made and they
always want to raise the bar they want
to do better than last year and so if
you show them what was published in the
past and I think that has happened year
after year where more and more prop
projects have gotten published and the
complexity of those projects has
continued to increase and the other
thing I'll do is post newspaper articles
about interesting things in the math
world interesting things in the physics
world that students would be ready to
understand and sometimes that sparks
nice ideas and creating creating
contests on the art contest obviously
they get very very excited for that
around februari and that kind of that
starts the spirit of competition so that
later in the year when we make the demos
they they really want to create
something neat so thank you aaron let's
see well is there anything else in there
no we're good in terms of picking
project ideas I let them go in any
direction that they want to it's more
about creating something that they have
a vision foreign that they're interested
in rather than it having to be about the
curriculum from the course now in in the
as they start creating it does end up
that you know they learn how to plot
things in spherical coordinates they
learn how to plot in cylindrical
coordinates they learn some optimization
a lot of that actually does come in so
they don't expect it ahead of time but
they end up doing calculus for these
projects anyway for the most part so
makes me happy but I went through old
projects and figured out that proxy
these are very approximate ratios of the
different subject areas but physics
seems to be the big one it's sad for me
but mathematics always takes second
place to physics for these projects and
then we do get a lot of biology
chemistry computer science and then
fractals every year there's a billiards
project every year someone wants to
really recreate billiards in Mathematica
and sometimes it goes better than than
other years epidemiology especially when
the Zika virus was
was the winds still bad thing to talk
about but when that was really big news
at the time a lot of students were very
interested in epidemiology we have a
zombie projects even with epidemiology
okay berwyn let's keep going he's
telling me to go sorry to keep moving
and I'm going to wrap up soon but in
terms of picking project ideas the ideas
that I suggest usually our last place
sometimes the student will see a project
that I suggest and like I yeah I'll do
that usually it's something that they
saw in a different class a difficult
problem from physics for example that
they're like like make a demo of this a
student hobby or interest is big or
sometimes just browsing the wolfram
demonstrations project and looking at
what other people have created sometimes
they'll see a neat project that someone
else has come up with and they'll say oh
I could use this same idea but in this
direction or I could take this physics
idea and turn it into this project
that's similar but you know not exactly
the same alright berwyn and then I'll
make this quick but at the beginning of
the demonstration project the first few
days I do spend some time helping them
learn how to use Mathematica in a way
that they're not used to because they
had spent an entire school year learning
how to use Mathematica to solve calculus
problems and I need to transition them
to learning how to use Mathematica to
create an interactive demo using
manipulate so there's there's things
that we don't talk about earlier in the
year local versus global variables
showing multiple graphics outputs all in
one plots in a very precise way so
there's some of those things so if you
expand that berwyn is it just taking a
long time yeah I'm not going to spend
very long on that but this is something
that we create in class we start with a
really simple really you know their
first demo with a sine plot and then we
just keep adding more and more to it and
that this takes about a class period and
by the end of that class period they
have a code base that they can refer to
just is basically a template for putting
their their project into so you know
they learn how to move on move around
controls a lot of this is from the
Wolfram introduction to manipulate
article so they can learn the same thing
from that article but this is kind of
scaffolding it and adding in these
features you know a little
at a time until there's certain things
they need to know how to do they have to
be able to label controls they need to
know how to put the you know labels into
their plots and by the end of the period
they have a pretty pretty neat little
little demo that they can use as a
template right and then the main thing
that I want to communicate is that
adopting a net math style philosophy or
near classroom does help with getting
great results out of students so what
I've learned over the years in it at
first I was uncomfortable with this idea
but after several years years of
teaching this way it became now I can't
imagine going back but just really
believing that students can and will do
amazing things when you give them
freedom to experiment when you give them
open-ended problems when you give them a
chance to express themselves pursue
their interests the great thing about
the net math program is there are
problems that the students can just you
know if they're not interested in it
they can solve it they can give their
explanation and they can move on and
that problem might not be meaningful for
them but they learned something and then
there's other problems that they might
see that they are really interested in
and it's a you know it's a it's
something that they want to explore more
in it's a it's a sandbox so they can
keep writing and they can keep putting
more code in and make that problem their
own and once the student has that
mindset they can continue that when they
jump into a project like this all right
and now time to showcase a few of my
famed former students Robert all right
um so as it says on the slide my name is
robert andrews i'm a senior at the
University of Illinois here in Champaign
I study math and computer science and in
terms of I guess the impact this project
had I think it's really interesting to
look at visualizations of concepts that
don't necessarily lend themselves well
to some sort of visualization or
intuition when you first read about them
in particular in what I do with with
computer science I'm rather interested
in the theoretical side of things
looking at algorithms things like that
and I actually helped teach one of the
algorithms courses here at the
University one of the things I find
interesting is there are a host of
algorithms in particular algorithms on
graphs where if you just read a formal
description of it
sure student can maybe understand it but
there's a lot of intuition from seeing
how the thing plays out and so I think
you know having experience with that is
really useful in terms of my
demonstration when I was back in high
school I was particularly interested in
looking at conic sections and how the
formulas actually mapped out to the
geometry of the curves so what I did is
just wrote up a little demonstration
where you can you know pick your
favorite conic section it's really slow
I did not try to optimize this thing but
you can move it around a little bit
adjust some of the parameters of the
curve it oh boy I won't play around with
it too much there you go sure you're
going to adjust some of the parameters
of the curve show different interesting
parts of the curve things like that and
then it shows how the equation for the
curve changes as you move it around and
in particular I was interested in
looking at how you can rotate connex in
the plane and how that influences the
equation for it and you get this XY term
that shows up as a student you know I
could read about this in a book and and
see okay you know this is where the
rotation comes from blah blah blah blah
blah but actually seeing how that
changed as i manipulated the thing i
just thought that was really interesting
gave me a somewhat better intuition of
how these things work so that's made him
and robert just interrupt you the part
that i was excited about this project
with this project is we learn how to do
all of this with with the lips a--'s and
circles parametrically in the in the
calc three course and i like that you
were had that opportunity to build upon
that and those are all XY equations so
having that exact connection that was
exciting for me for me on my end at
least hi I'm Dan Johnson I'm a junior at
the University of Illinois at
urbana-champaign and I study computer
science and engineering physics as well
as a minor in mathematics my project was
a physics project it was uh involving
amperes law which is one of the
maxwell's for electromagnetic equations
and it relates a magnetic field to
current density and changing electric
field but if we
there's a steady state then it's really
just comparing current density and
magnetic field so kind of what involved
what was involved in this project was
showing a the magnetic field given a
infinitely long wire with a uniform
current density and uniform me meaning
that it doesn't vary the current density
doesn't vary throw the position of the
wire so in this example that you have a
cylinder in the middle which kind of its
that's the wire itself and then you have
what's called an ampere Ian loop and
that amp earring and loop is where we
measure the magnetic field it's kind of
hard to see here but those are a bunch
of magnetic field vectors or what I
attempted to demonstrate and it's a
cylindrical e symmetric because an
infinitely long wires symmetric and
there's a few interesting aspects you
can see that if you increase the
distance the measurement distance so the
radius of the Empyrean loop then you're
going to have a one over R dependency so
as we increase this I you can see the
magnetic field strength at the bottom so
it's going to go down as you increase
the measurement point but what's
interesting is if you have a larger wire
or a wire of larger radius and you
increase the weight for that for a
second you increase the measurement
distance the Empyrean loop as it
increases is going to encapsulate more
and more of the current so it's actually
going to have a it's going to be
proportionate the magnetic fields can be
proportional to the radius of the
Empyrean loop as it increases throughout
the wire but then once you get outside
of the wire it's going to have that one
over R dependency that we saw before and
then another quick example of how this
works is it's a right-hand rule so if
you flip the current around then it's
going to flip the other way just like
it's going to be the negative five head
directions at the positive x hat
direction and how this demonstration is
kind of related to what I do now is I'm
currently working on a fusion device on
campus at the University of Illinois
where we magnetically confine a plasma
and so we have a ton of different Magnus
we have toroidal magnets or create a
toroidal magnetic field we have helical
magnets we have vertical magnets and we
have to we also have the the plasma
plasma itself is constitutes a current
so that plasma creates a plasma current
which is going to create its own
magnetic field so we have to account for
all these different factors in a
superposition of all these magnetic
fields to actually determine the
magnetic structure of the system to
confine the plasma so that's kind of how
it relates to what I do now and that is
what I have everyone i'm kevin i was a
2013 friend grid and i'm now a senior at
northwestern getting my bachelor's and
master's in mechanical engineering with
a concentration in fluid dynamics I plan
on working post graduation and after
working for a couple years in the
industry i want to see if further
schooling is for me or not um so the
impact this project had on me like I
honestly have nothing but good things to
say about this both as a high school
senior it was a really great thing for
me because it was post AP tests all that
stress that was built up I could release
by like putting my energy into making
this project really great and then it
also helped me it gave me an environment
where i had no restrictions or a few
restrictions on what I could do and I
really got to explore like what it was
to code or make a demonstration that was
my own which proved to be really helpful
as an incoming engineering student at
Northwestern because I was immediately
introduced to matlab which is what
northwestern engineers use all the time
and it was super easy to pick up and i
really attributed that to the experience
i had with this project because uh I I
just learned the skill set that I needed
to succeed in programming thanks to the
work that I did with this um and I've
used matlab ever since then
in a variety of like high level
engineering classes and research
projects most recently I've been working
in the northwestern neuroscience and
robotics lab and doing all of analyzing
data using programming and I really
think this was a huge experience for me
I really liked um I will explain my
project after berwyn talks since we
worked on this together alright cool um
so I'm sperwan I'm a senior and computer
science at the U of I well I my
interests are with data and this project
turned out to be like a really good
introduction to taking data in this case
like music notes and manipulating that
in some way on campus I'm part of a CM
and this one group called cig music and
all the stuff that we do is we take all
sorts of information be it like
interactive data like using a Microsoft
Kinect or all different sorts of
controllers and taking that data making
music out of it and that's kind of
similar to what we did here in our
senior capstone project and on campus
we've create these projects for
engineering open house which every March
we invite all middle schoolers and high
schoolers from around the area to try
and get them involved in engineering
show them what you can do with
technology and I feel like music is one
of those things that everyone can sort
of understand it's like one of those
universal languages that even if you
don't understand English you can kind of
listen to music and understand and
appreciate it so that's sort of like
this whole project thing that it was
this whole thing capstone was an
introduction for me to take an idea and
implement it in some way and that's
definitely helped me through my career
with creating all these projects in
clubs I'm also part of women in computer
science organization on our campus and I
run the tech team which is basically
leading and helping a woman in the
organization create projects and get
them more involved and not let them get
discouraged
throughout all the process of being a
computer science student on campus so I
guess we can demo our thing now so the
way this project came about actually was
we were we're both musicians so we
obviously gravitated towards the note
producing capabilities of Mathematica
and we started out by actually making a
version of macklemore's song thrift shop
and we we were like tinkering with a
different notes in it or the semi tones
of the scales and that's how we came up
with the idea of varying a bunch of
musical attributes of some famous songs
to create a demonstration yeah when you
press play it takes about six seconds or
soda can't have to give it time to load
I noticed it again uh you're the
computer scientist I don't know it might
not have been a wise design decision on
my own zoo put lots of demos all good
berwyn
see if we have the patience
alright that's how to
so if it doesn't work you're gonna have
to not maximize it yeah
looks like it's executed
so I guess it would just so you can see
the visual of the note and we can change
these variables like the mode there's a
couple different ones we have different
songs that we put in and they had to be
like not copyright and we have plenty of
instruments that are all built into the
wool friend language and if we're
growing give it one minute they're so it
was loading from the Wolfram research
server okay so it probably yeah it might
work in a couple seconds yeah let's try
again let's press play if not we can
move on we could always come back during
question the QA and it might just start
playing music at us all right well let's
come let's come back to it yeah yeah hey
everyone I'm Matt Nicholson I'm a
sophomore engineering student at
northwestern university i'm studying
computer science and mathematical
methods and the social sciences which is
a mouthful and a post-graduation I'm
really hope to work in kind of policy
research particularly the economics of
education because I I recognize that you
know being part of Fremd with great
teachers like mr. GU Tony had an
outstanding opportunity and I would just
like to research a little bit more about
you know why why that's possible in some
cases but not everywhere so i'll have a
roshan introduced himself as well again
so I'm Roshan I'm a sophomore here at
the University of Illinois I'm studying
Computer Engineering and so kind of this
this project helped me focus a little
bit more on my interests so kind of post
graduation I want to go into a grad
school and focus on the research there
but then after their I want to go to an
industry rd kind of working on
developing tools that improve people's
lives so
it's it's kind of the aspect of this
project that really helped me was kind
of getting into that mode of research
like if you have to do something you
have to begin at the basics and try to
move from there yeah also so not present
right here is our third team member who
worked on this Jenny a so I just you
know very definitely worth mentioning
that she was a for sure a contributor to
this project so in terms of impact this
project and working in this course with
Mathematica was kind of my first intro
into a programming language and I found
really cool like what you could do and
like the capabilities of Wolfram and
that made me kind of want to explore
that further and that's definitely led
to where I am today also we got to pick
a problem and kind of work out a
solution as roshan mentioned which is
obviously something you do all the time
in research so one of the one of the
most interesting aspects of our research
was I have a little picture here was
that actually the the winter after we
did it our junior year of high school so
the winter of our senior year of high
school we actually got to present this
at a research symposium that was being
held so we got to expand beyond just the
results of a demo making it interactive
but kind of talk about what does it mean
so it was our project is based on this
we called it the spatial efficiency of a
bifold or something that we have in our
homes a simple closet door that's able
to open closed so we were trying to
explore one the curve beyond the curve
behind it right so like why would you
choose a bifold door versus just a
normal open and closed door and then but
then we wanted to expand then to seeing
like okay will be the benefits of
increasing the number of folds in a door
or how could you apply these math
medic things that we've learned during
the year into things that we see in our
daily lives so we got the opportunity we
actually had a if you can if you can see
it kind of unclear but we actually put a
little bifold closet door in front of
our presentation to make it a little bit
more opening but that was that was kind
of our the benefit we got to go through
the entire research process but on a
little smaller scale but then we also
got to show something that we were
interested in and and proved that like
we were able to expand this simple
concept into something that could
potentially mean something more and so
yeah now I guess we're gonna we're going
to show off our our project a little bit
here so here we have side by side a
bifold door and just like typical double
doors and part of this project as part
of this project excuse me we went
through and enter I've actually what
this this curve over oh yeah yeah what
this what this curve would be so if you
notice it's kind of hard to see and
we'll wait for it to come back I guess
let's see okay all right yeah perfect so
what you can see here is that initially
the bifold or the curve that it sweeps
out is determined by the hinge of the
door and then after a certain point it
stops being determined by the hinge but
rather the the second door so let's
let's see that yet
oh dang okay all right Roshan since this
is the last slide you theoretically
while he's talking you might be able to
go to close that completely closed out
of Mathematica download the CDF and it
might it might grow faster because we
have so many demos all in one full
notebook I think it's freaking out I
probably needed more more ram so wait
wait a sec for for that to happen here
I won't let you anymore you have to you
have to download it but you'd want to
close out of ya
so I'll talk a little bit more about
like why this was an interesting problem
for us while we're waiting for this to
go so you know obviously as college
students space comes at a premium so we
wanted to figure out a way to maximize
our space so you know it follows that we
would study a problem like the
efficiency of a bifold door we're in a
space where you know you don't have a
whole lot of room so as you can see you
can kind of see from that screenshot
down there that at the very bottom we
have like a running count sort of of the
amount of area that the curve has swept
out and you can see that or you will see
very shortly that the bi-fold doors are
are much more efficient in terms of
saving space and another thing that we
found that Roshan alluded to is that if
you were to continue with us and keep
increasing the number of folds it
obviously gets more efficient but then
you have you know real world
considerations like the thickness of a
door and how practical is it for you
know you to have a door that's has 20
folds in it but yeah okay I think we're
up and running hey Matt remember when I
told you we should be ready for a
technical difficulties I didn't know
what was gonna happen to at least one of
us absolutely all right so let's let's
start we start without the curve yeah
all right so yeah so we're just going to
sweep through this real fast you know
side by side of doors in case you don't
know how doors work oh so now you know
we can we can throw in the the curve
here and you know you see the on the
right you just have you know two circles
and then on the left it starts off as a
circle and then it the the second half
of it is an ash
wait yes Astro sorry excuse me so now
let's uh oh the intersection point is
there okay yeah so you can see that
little black dot right there on both
sides that's the point that's actually
getting swept out so as the door opens
and closes the intersection point kind
of travels for the bifold door from the
hinge all the way down to the end of the
door so yeah it's cool stuff for sure do
you want to talk about how we came up
with this no you can just click more
really quickly and Justin if someone
wants to read your derivation it's all
there for sure they they were very good
at showing their work I was very proud
yeah all right and I think this is
perfect timing for the the Q&A if
there's any questions about any of the
individual projects or the the idea for
the project as a whole thank you
everybody for attending
[Applause]